a man who admitted to killing his child
was supposed to learn his fate this
morning but that did not occur the eight
news now investigators have been
following the case against Paul Jones
Vanessa Murphy has the latest twist in
the case from downtown Las Vegas
Paul Jones refusing to show up at his
sentencing he's currently in jail just
across the street from the Regional
Justice Center here but he likely knows
he's heading to prison after finally
admitting to abusing and killing his son
refused to be transported today Paul
Jones a no-show in court Thursday he
previously pleaded guilty to
first-degree murder and child abuse the
victim his 13 year old son Aaron
this is Paul Jones lying during an
interview with 8 news now in jail after
his arrest in 2017. he later changed his
story while the murder case against Paul
Jones unfolded the eight news now
investigators learned Aaron Jones was
failed in multiple ways he was placed
with his father while he was already on
probation for child abuse Paul Jones
proceeded to severely abuse Aaron and
then no one reported the child missing
for months dijanae Thomas Aaron's mother
filed a lawsuit against the child
welfare system that civil case is also
ongoing it's hard to believe my son is
dead now the sentencing is scheduled for
February 16th and that sentencing can
happen whether Jones agrees to appear or
not the judge mentioning video will be
an option from jail
reporting in downtown Las Vegas Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now
Clark County District Attorney judge
Tiara Jones said Paul Jones must appear
via video by quote any means necessary